collecter et recycler plutôt que jeter
c'est à valentigney dans une entreprise
d'insertion spécialisée dans les déchets
électroniques et électriques que yannick
jadot a débuté sa visite au pays de
l'automobile dans cette ancienne friche
faurecia le député européen sortant
martèle que le développement industriel
peut être compatible avec le
développement durable
c'est ça qu'on est venu voir ici et
c'est ça qu'on veut porter dans la
campagne des entreprises qui intègrent
l'environnement qui intègre le
l'émancipation de chacune et de chacun
dans l'entreprise qui intègre insertion
sociale et qui réussissent ça marche
l'écologie ça marche un message que
yannick jadot et ses quatre colistiers
ont ensuite répété à une poignée de
chefs d'entreprise pas forcément acquis
à leur cause
autour d'un déjeuner bio et végétarien
en garde d'elle il ya un mot qui était
un peu tabou c'est la décroissance
aujourd'hui de toutes façons de société
elle ne croise plus elle arrive aux
limites de ce qu'elles peuvent exploiter
des ressources
aujourd'hui on à l'industrie automobile
par exemple sur le nord franche comté
comment travailler sur le démantèlement
de ces véhicules pour pouvoir les
peut-être les réinjecter retructurer
l'acier le plastique elle est réinjecté
dans l'économie ça c'est important parce
que nous sommes sur une planète finie et
que s'ils ne le faisons pas attention à
la réflexion des ressources et ben c'est
un climat vraiment de compétition que
nous allons affronter et les premières
victimes ce seront toujours les mêmes
les plus faibles conjugués économie et
écologie
c'est le pari réussi par ce fabricant
d'articles de cuisine haut de gamme de
fesches le châtel ici les produits sont
garantis à vie pa d'obsolescence
programmée
l'électricité est à 100% d'origine
renouvelable
l'eau est recyclée tous les ingrédients
d'une entreprise modèle pour les
écologistes